[Funny Music]
Herond: When I start my company
With two of my friends
I decided to try Edjing
It was the first free DJ application last week.
The idea came from my passion for music.
I used to play DJ during student concerts
At the moment I do not see great ease in using
Another solution to create a mix of songs.
Today we have more than 60 million USD.
The edjing application is the most likely to bring in dollar profits.
There are branches of our company in 182 countries
So I'm very proud of my team.
When we launched our apps on Android
This system has become the biggest contributor to our company's prosperity.
We earn 50% of our revenue on the Android platform
We also earn over 70% of our earnings in dollars via Android.
Piet: Our mission is
Provide great musical instruments for music lovers.
We think that's why we're successful on Android
Is the fact of our dedication in
Design great and high quality applications for users.
The other reason is tools
Provided by Google Play Publishers.
The multidimensional design was a big breakthrough for the design team.
It is more integrated and easier to use.
This has really encouraged designers to discover Android features and enthusiasm.
We really care about the voice response time factor.
We design music apps
These applications must be very responsive
The efficiency is also very great.
For DJ applications, the response time should be as low as possible.
Dilipin: Represents voice time response time
Between song play time
And actually broadcast the music from the loudspeaker.
And the new Android Marshmallow devices
Such as Nexus 9, Nexus 5X, and Nexus 6P
The response time is less than 20 milliseconds.
Thus, we can provide an application
More stable and faster response
Which improves the experience for DJs.
BAYET: We created the Mixfader this year.
It lets you mix songs and play them
Directly from your smartphone or tablet
Via Bluetooth.
Dilipin: Our Marshmallow software developers
Are able to handle large communication processes
Between an Android device and a Mixfader.
In other platforms the minimum is 20 milliseconds
For Bluetooth connections.
We were able to reach a response time of 7.5 milliseconds.
So the Android platform provides us with the best experience to use.
BAYET: At first we provided free trial applications
But we started experimenting with ads.
Our revenue has doubled through AdMob
At a rate of two or three times as applicable.
We prefer Google Play because it makes it easier to interact with users.
When they add reviews about our apps to the store
We can respond directly to them.
As well as uploading an update very quickly.
This is very useful to us in fact.
Herond: Today, DJiT occupies the company
Ranked 10th among the largest successful music application companies.
We aspire to be ranked first
Over the next two years.
Thanks to improved voice response time on Android
We can create new music apps for users
We are very excited about that.
[Funny Music]